comes now plaintiff Jane Doe and by and through undersign counsel
and files her reply to defendant Steven Bonnel II's opposition
to motion to file declarations under seal and as grounds therefore
states as follows plaintiff's motion for leave to file declarations
under seal motion seeks to have the unredacted declarations of
three witnesses filed under seal in order to protect their identities
pursuant to local rule B plaintiff attached the redacted versions
of the three declarations to her simultaneously filed reply to
the opposition to the motion for prelim Preliminary injunction
reply DKT. The portions of the declarations that are redacted
are only those that would serve to identify the witnesses substantive
content is not redacted. Defendant Bonnel opposes the motion
on three purported grounds. I plaintiffs failure to meet and
confer. Roman two plaintiffs refusal to identify the names of
the declarance. In Roman three, the rule upon which plaintiff
relies is not applicable. OP P for the reasons set forth below.
Defendant's arguments are unavailing. Furthermore, it bears noting
that defendant fails to address the merits of the motion and
the critical need to have the identity of these declarants protected.
A meet and confer. Plaintiff did not fail to meet and confer.
Plaintiff made efforts to meet and confer but was unable to obtain
defendants's position prior to the deadline for filing. See plaintiff's
notice submitting amended certificate of conferral. Plaintiff
then continued with her efforts to confer with defendant and
resolve the issues raised, but plaintiff's efforts proved fruitless.
It see also meet and confer emails. plaintiff complied with both
the letter and the spirit of local rule A. Moreover, it is apparent
from defendants's opposition that he was completely unwilling
to reach any reasonable resolution of the issue. Thus, defendants's
first ground for denying leave to file under seal is without
basis in law or fact. B. Plaintiff's refusal to identify the
names. Defendant's second purported ground for denying the motion
is also without merit. Plaintiff's refusal to identify the names
of the declarance prior to the court's ruling on the motion is
not a reason to deny the motion.
Rather, it is merely a nonsensical demand by defendant. The precise
purpose of the motion is to protect the identities of the declarance.
These declarations contain highly sensitive, private, and confidential
information regarding the non-consensual distribution of explicit
materials and related communications involving the witnesses,
plaintiff, and individuals. Defendants insistence that he be
prematurely provided with the names of the declarance prior to
the court's ruling on the motion would defeat the very purpose
of the motion. C. Local rule B is the only applicable rule. Moreover,
defendants demand for the names of the declarance and are the
unredacted versions of the declarations prior to the court's
ruling on the motion is not supported by the applicable local
rule governing the process for filing documents under seal. Local
rule B provides in relevant part if prior to the issuance of
a ruling on the motion to file under seal the moving party elects
or is required to publicly file a pleading motion memorandum
or other document that attaches or reveals the content of the
proposed sealed material.
Then the moving party must redact from the public filing all
content that is the subject of the motion to file defendant's
opposition. Misleads the court by failing to disclose that he
is already aware of the legal identity of witness abidenced by
a recent discovery request from defendant using the witness legal
name as well as notice of defendant subpoena that he intends
to serve on witness abink which includes her legal name and home
address under seal emphasis supplied.
Thus, the rule specifically allows the filer to publicly file
a redacted version of the document if feasible and simultaneously
submit a motion to file under seal the unredacted version. This
is the process that was followed by plaintiff. Local rule B does
not require movement to provide opposing council with the unredacted
version before the court rules on the sealing motion as that
would defeat the purpose of the rule. Defendants's reliance on
local rule FA misplaced. This rule is not applicable to redacted
filings accompanied by a ceiling motion. The only applicable
rule in the instant situation is rule B, which does not require
disclosure prior to the court's ruling on the
motion. Thus, defendants's third and last ground for opposing
the motion is also baseless. D. The critical need to protect
the identities of the witnesses. Defendant's opposition completely
ignores the substantive basis for the motion. A good cause for
sealing the identities is established since the declarations
contain sensitive and private intimate details and Roman 2 public
disclosure of the identities of these witnesses would expose
the witnesses to harassment, embarrassment, possible harm and
retaliation. See motion as set forth an exhibit to defendants's
opposition. Defendant has publicly threatened physical harm to
individuals that have spoken out against him and in support of
plaintiff for JSDLK and Cumin them if I could. It'd show up to
their house and do it. I do want someone to JSDLK though or Lav
or Mr. Girl or Cuman. All those people can go die. Defendant
regularly streams on his YouTube channel the details of this
case including confidential details from meat and confers held
between council. After the reply and the motion were filed, he
streamed about the filings, showing them on his screen, reading
excerpts aloud, and providing vitriolic and defamatory commentary.
YouTube video it equals baammoo ws. This video has been viewed
times to date. In it, defendant accuses plaintiff of extorting
and blackmailing him of insane lies, of a total lie. Defendant
accuses witness ABMCC declaration of lying and perjury. He refers
to the undersign council as disgusting and repeatedly accuses
the undersign council of grabbing random people to perjure themselves.
Apparently, all of this commentary is approved by defendants
council. I pass everything that I publish by my lawyers
Furthermore, despite the protective order entered by this court
to protect plaintiff Jane Does identity, defendant publicly disclosed
plaintiff Jane Does legal name on his social media platform.
See YouTube video. It equals everything. Obviously, we'll say
much I can talk about, but like
um likely having conversations where she's literally saying depending
on Steven's response to this, I'll decide like if I have to go
nuclear or not and um but don't worry like stuff over the holidays
cuz I don't want to make people's like holidays feel bad. And
it's like holy [__] like, "Well, what the fuck?"
And then when the demand is 500,000 to a million dollars, it's
like, "Wait, what the fuck?" And it's getting higher like every
single time she talks to somebody. I'm like, "Wait, excuse me.
This is cuz Yeah. I don't know. It's just like, isn't this extortion?"
Uh, I'm not going to say that because that would be a crime.
Uh, and I'm still consulting with my lawyer on that. Um, but
it, uh, you know, if you read the elements of it, gets pretty
close to
In this same video, defendant posts plaintiff's private messages
to him about her emotional distress and thoughts due to his non-consensual
sharing of the video and then mocks and ridicules her. He then
tells his subscribers that plaintiffs emotional distress was
contrived solely for the purpose of extorting him. It is readily
apparent that the three declarants, Abby, MC, and witnesses A
and B, need the court to seal their identities in order to protect
them from the public intimidation, retaliation, and psychological
harm relentlessly perpetrated by defendant. Further relief may
be required given defendants continued efforts to dox and intimidate
both the plaintiff and the witnesses in this matter.
Tellingly, not once during the meet and confer process did defendants
council offer to maintain the confidentiality of the names of
the declarance pending the court's ruling on the motion. Wherefore
plaintiff's motion, reply and exhibits having been considered,
plaintiff prays that her motion for leave to file declarations
under seal be granted, and plaintiff further prays for such other
and general relief as the court deems necessary and proper. dated
May.